[Música]
buenos días y bienvenidos a la
entrevista de france 24 nuestra invitada
es irina benedicto va la fiscal general
de ucrania quien está con nosotros desde
la capital ucraniana kiev gracias por
estar con nosotros buenos días y muchas
gracias estimados televidentes para
invitar en este programa
la ofensiva militar rusa empezó en el
este del país en el tomba
después de lo que se descubrió en los
alrededores de kiev principalmente en
bouchard
piensa que se descubrirán crímenes
similares de mariupol o en el resto del
donbass
si hablamos de mariupol mariupol está
ubicada en el donbass
entonces pienso que se descubrirán
cifras cada vez más elevadas erbol
y daños cada vez más graves
entiendo bien eso porque ahora ya
disponemos es el caso de una subida
niños y esto no incluye na mariupol
no sabemos exactamente lo que está
sucediendo en la ciudad del marido
huevos es por esta razón que cuando
salgamos el mariupol cuando ya no esté
ocupada
veremos ejemplos de crímenes a gran
escala no solamente crímenes de guerra o
crímenes de lesa humanidad
creo que vamos a encontrar evidencias de
genocidios desde mayo por duración
federations tanto hasta la federación
rusa claramente tenemos que comprobarlo
todo mecanismo
hacer lo necesario para que nuestro
mecanismo de investigación lo verifique
además tenemos que enfrentarnos a una
situación muy difícil no solamente en la
región del donbass y de lugar
por ejemplo en mykolaiv o partir esas
dos ciudades siguen siendo bombardeadas
y por esta razón todo el este de ucrania
se encuentra en gran peligro
tenemos informaciones hablé con su
ministro de relaciones exteriores de los
crematorios móviles que rusia llevó a
mariupol markarián probablemente para
esconder las pruebas de los crímenes que
encontramos en lucha y en borobia en
canca es decir usted tiene esas mismas
informaciones desde el terreno
y es totalmente posible si yo cuento con
la misma información recolectada en el
terreno sobre el uso de esos crematorios
y el número de víctimas resultará tan
elevado que puede hacer que estén
quemando cadáveres ahora mismo pero
vamos a descubrir un gran número de
víctimas adicionales
usted acaba de hablar de las personas
que se encuentran desaparecidas
embajador ante las naciones unidas
afirmó que más de 500.000 ucranianos
habían sido deportados la fuerza a rusia
de los cuales más de 120 mil son niños
usted también tiene las mismas cifras
tenemos esas cifras efectivamente otra
vez utilizamos esas cifras desde un
punto de vista operacional
ya que soy fiscal no puedo dar eso
sifres antes de haber terminado
todas las investigaciones
pero lo que tenemos ahora son esos
territorios en zonas de combate
la mayoría están ocupados y por eso no
podemos llevar a cabo en nuestra
investigación en el terreno
pero entendemos que hay números muy
elevados de civiles desplazados de
ucrania
hacia rusia
dentro de los cuales hay niños y lo
sabemos exactamente lo que está
sucediendo ahora
y dónde están esos niños y por supuesto
entendemos que no se puede iniciar un
proceso judicial o llevar a cabo las
investigaciones como tal antes de estar
en el terreno pero primero tenemos que
asegurarnos de ganar la guerra y luego
empezaremos a castigar a los culpables
las zonas a las cuales tienen acceso son
aquellas que están en los alrededores de
kiev y woodside mansión particularmente
buche y boro dianca
cuántos muertos han podido encontrar e
identificar
y de esas cifras cuántos son niños
la última cifra fue de 1.500 civiles
asesinados el número de niños debería
verificarlo pero tenemos muchos más
territorios en la región de quiebre que
siguen minado por esta razón no podemos
tener la cifra exacta en esta región
aunque ya no esté ocupada no podemos
terminar todos los territorios
alrededor de la región de club
todavía estamos en ese proceso
[Música]
en lo relacionado a los crímenes
sexuales existe información según la
cual han tenido lugar en muchas y en
otros lugares maybe other place tests
que han encontrado
desafortunadamente hemos encontrado que
los crímenes de carácter sexual han sido
perpetrados en todos los territorios
ocupados
en los territorios que ahora estando
ocupados tenemos casos de víctimas
concretas con las cuales podemos hablar
ostras pero usted sabe que la gente está
tan estresada que a veces no están en
condiciones de hablar
on the ground además tenemos mucha
información práctica de sacerdotes
alcaldes periodistas en el terreno que
corroboran esos abusos sexuales
que no son solamente perpetrados contra
las mujeres sino también contra los
hombres los niños y en algunos casos
abusos sexuales contra mujeres mayores
de bob verbeeck por eso de nuevo me
gustaría decir que cuando tengamos las
cifras exo camps y ahora un número aún
más elevado de crímenes de carácter
sexual en vogue
porque esto ocurre en todos los
territorios en guerra sin importar el
país o la región del planeta
primero en estado debe ganar la guerra y
luego garantizar la seguridad de las
víctimas para que puedan hablar y
después de eso el sistema jurídico debe
tratar los casos
llevarlos ante la justicia y las
víctimas nos hablarán en cuantas
investigaciones han abierto desde el
inicio de la guerra
es un número muy elevado el total de
crímenes de guerra y de crímenes
relacionados con crímenes de guerra
superan los 10.000 hay más de 7.000
casos de investigación de crímenes de
guerra y 3000 casos de investigación de
casos relacionados con crímenes de
guerra es un número muy alto de
investigaciones desafortunadamente todos
los días tenemos nuevos casos sobre los
cuales tenemos que iniciar
investigaciones tostadas por ejemplo en
la región dejar que cardio brillante hoy
tenemos casos de bombardeos contra
civiles
bombardeos contra objetivos civiles
cada vez que hay nuevos hechos tenemos
que iniciar una nueva investigación
a quienes se dirigen estas
investigaciones a siempre soldados
mercenarios o personas de alto rango
es una muy buena pregunta nuestro
objetivo son todos los criminales
potenciales o people todos los que
perpetraron crímenes de guerra en
ucrania
hemos oído por parte de los prisioneros
de guerra que en ucrania que ellos no
son combatientes que no son militares
como tal
y todos mataron civiles o bombardearon
objetivos civiles
o confiscaron propiedades de civiles o
perpetraron otros crímenes
entonces son personas que cometieron
esos crímenes aunque no sean militares
además tenemos cifras muy elevadas de
agresiones cometidas
por la federación de rusia
en contra de ucrania ahora tenemos casi
600 sospechosos
ya six 2 se trata de políticos de alto
rango de la federación rusa militares de
alto rango
la gente se propaganda de alto rango
por ejemplo el ministro del interior
colocar tierra
y entiendo que este número importante de
sospechosos debería ser responsable
de la agresión de ucrania
con eso la cifra llegaría a más de 1000
personas
de siempre sobrevivir putin
vladimir putin es la persona más
influyente en la federación rusa anne
waters y obviamente es responsable de
todo lo que ha sido hecho en nombre de
la federación de rusia pero según la
legislación ucraniana que ha
implementado la legislación nacional
el derecho humanitario y el derecho
internacional el presidente el ministro
de relaciones exteriores y el primer
ministro
según la legislación nacional tienen
inmunidad
es la razón por la cual quiero trabajar
en estrecha colaboración y estoy
completamente abierta a una cooperación
con el fiscal de la corte penal
internacional
joe porque las instituciones
internacionales
no reconocen esta inmunidad wright
pero usted quisiera que esos casos
fueran juzgados en su raíz en la corte
penal internacional que acaba de
mencionar o en otros países
estamos dispuestos a colaborar con otros
estados de hecho ucrania en este momento
ha iniciado una investigación con 13
estados sobre los crímenes de guerra
perpetrados en ucrania
y además tenemos equipos conjuntos de
investigación con polonia y lituania
a través de la plataforma euronews y
hacemos eso de manera conjunta y para mí
como fiscal general de ucrania
es muy importante tener decisiones que
sean tomadas por los tribunales
ucranianos y por jueces nombrados por el
cráneo
confía en sus instituciones
quiero hacer todo lo posible para tener
éxito en este aspecto en su vez acceso
sin embargo estoy completamente abierta
a cualquier colaboración con otros
fiscales u otras instituciones
internacionales
es un genocidio lo que está ocurriendo
en ucrania hubo una discusión entre el
presidente francés y el presidente
ucraniano el presidente francés dijo que
no quiere utilizar esta palabra el
presidente celeste afirmó que esto lo
había ofrecido desde su punto de vista
desde un punto de vista legal se alcanza
el umbral de genocidio
iniciamos una investigación sobre los
cargos de genocidio
pues desde los primeros días de la
guerra
enjuiciamos personas sobre la base de
hechos concretos
según los cuales agentes de propaganda
rusos
habían escrito libros sobre la
desnazificación de ucranianas a quienes
se creían tipo y en los cuales hablaban
de un genocidio contra los ucranianos
hippies y reader y además el presidente
excelencia es nuestro jefe de estado
antes trans y entiende muy bien que la
federación de rusia
y que los militares rusos ahora quieren
destruir no sólo nuestro estado en
calidad de estado sino también destruir
la población y matar a los ucranianos
quieren intentar que nuestra nación
desaparezca como un eco ahora que hits o
un evento histórico es que el presidente
silencia como jefe de estado de su país
lo declaró un litro nation insólito yo
soy fiscal y hago todo lo posible para
intentar encontrar la evidencia que
permite demostrar este crimen a gran
escala se va a ver y después de esto les
haremos conclusiones
irina benedicto wa muchas gracias por
haber contestado a las preguntas de
france 24 y muchas gracias a ustedes por
haber seguido este programa en nuestro
canal
[Música]